good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the Chast happy th Thursday God
we're in the latter half time flies when
we're having a girly swirly week
together it does fly when we're having a
girly swirly week together it is you
know Thursday morning I've had a day
you've had a day claudy and I if you're
watching on YouTube are on two different
shows today two different planets that's
so sad I miss you on my planet I wish I
was on your planet yeah I'm on your
planet and you're kind of on Planet yeah
so I'm like dressed to the nines in a
dress a jacket and boots cuz I just came
from a bris an early morning bris for a
snip w a
snip with four my best friend and book
club member Margot mleo of Margo she had
a baby and not redhead that's really
confusing because we also have a Margo
in our book club true true this is my
book club of the bab we'll call her
Margaret that is her government name
okay Margaret um she had a baby so we
were up early at sh that's why I'm
looking modest actually I P my dress up
a little bit for the toast you know I
got to show these legs off totally where
are your boots from St they're really
cute thank you so much they're really
cute I might have to get them you should
by the way and for any of my wide CA
girlies like there's they space cool
even though I wore a really similar pair
of boots last night like I also want
those ones you look so comfortable and
cute than that's usually an insult like
you look comfortable it literally that
commercial you look tired that's that
commercial which one with the for cotton
and you look incredibly com comfortable
uh but I do look comfortable I'm like in
you know Mama on the mo on the road mode
no you're in like New York Mama mode New
York Mama mode um I got my merch Mama
hat on it's just like the cutest hat
ever we've been getting a lot of
questions about our merch being like
your website's broken no we're in like a
full Rebrand mode new merch is coming as
soon as it's done we're working on it we
want it to be premium our website is
down because you can no longer purchase
merch from for from us until the Rebrand
has laun until the new merch so that
will be in the next few weeks we're just
doing final edits but it's really cute
premier
in the first collection is I'm really
it's for the gires it's for the girlies
and it's going to be great and yeah so I
just am like I have my best I have like
my fanny pack I'm doing errands today
this is like an errands look you look
great thank you Claudia said I look so
cool and I obviously love your outfit
you look so cool like I would wear that
in a heartbeat we also looked fabulous
last night let's recap our evening we
were just kind of out and about in New
York city so the reason why you came to
New York was obviously to see your
beloved sister and make sure that Harry
got time with Auntie KOA but you were
really here because we did an event for
Amazon last night that was actually
fabulous yeah that was the reason for
the season and then I plan a little trip
around it did the same thing last year
was the Amazon holiday Suare they
brought all steens on Deck it was really
I don't think we've ever done like a
full working event together not in a
while not in a while and and not
anything like that we're proud of
legitimate yeah um it was fabulous and
actually on the way over here Ben was
like by the way who was at the party
like anyone cool I'm like oh my I
totally forgot to tell you we met Sarah
Jessica Parker and he was like really
how was she and he was like kind of
skeptical you know and what came out of
my mouth he was beyond shocked by
because we all like Sarah Jessica Parker
I believe her shoes as shape like sell
on Amazon she's like a partner of Amazon
fashion so she was there meeting a few
people and they were like do you want to
meet her we're like sure and I wasn't
really expecting much like I'm I'm
obviously Sex in the City fan I'm not
like a SJP like enormous fan I obviously
like admire her and she's you know
amazing when I tell you we all
individually like did a little meet and
greet with her and then we sat down on
couch and we were all just like kind of
giddy like she was really kind of
incredible she was so nice and warm and
like the two seconds of like Hi how are
you thanks for coming like so genuine
and lovely like when she asked how are
you like I think she actually wanted to
know the answer yeah she meant it we
were all so struck by her kindness Ben
was like what do you mean I'm like she
was like warm and welcoming and I
actually like love her now yeah she was
she didn't have to be that nice like she
was so nice and so you're right genuine
is the perfect word it just came off as
genuine like the things that she said
which were like Hi how are you welcome
thank you for coming whatever it was
anyone can say those things but just the
way that she said them with she meant
them I know she meant them and she
wasn't like weird she like put her arm
around me in the photo she not like
weird about being touched I just one
like I didn't see that on my list of
things that were going to happen last
night like leaving with an enormous love
and respect for SJP yeah she was awesome
she was awesome um and it was really a
fabulous event lots of people were there
I'm like kind of you know infiltrating
the real hostil of New York New
Generation so obviously everybody knows
I met Erin and Abe at Bravo Khan and
like we're just kind of like a thle now
um but I met Jessel which I know means
nothing to you because you don't watch a
show I know I saw an episode and a half
but do like do you know Jessel I know
that she's a big topic of conversation
from the season because she like started
off yikes energy like she was just it
did come out at the reunion that she
moved from Dallas for the show and once
everyone found that out they were like
oh she move for the show like you would
do it too no moving for a job it happens
every day it's really not a big deal um
but she was just giving like such try
hard energy in the beginning and I think
it really could have went South for her
but then in the last couple of episodes
like you really just saw that she's like
this nice girl who like definitely wants
to be famous but she like wants to be
friends with everyone she doesn't have a
mean bone in her body and everybody was
just coming for her so hard cuz she was
giving like like try hard kind of like
energy but the fans were like you know
what like she's a nice girl like she
didn't do she's not been mean to anyone
and she had this sort of resurgence she
rolling stone did a big feature on her
it was kind of like the year of Jessel
and I got to meet her and it was
actually really she was fabulous oh cool
yeah so like I'm just kind of
infiltrating I got to meet um and I know
uba now that you're becoming friends
with the
women if they reach out to you for
casting so there's a lot of talk about
them it's really not that no by the way
un heard of you're not that far off in
like age now from this new cast I I
actually think I'm a perfect candidate
for this show I would never do it like
ever okay but say they call you you
wouldn't immediately hang up the phone
would go through the I I would I would
go through the process and either hope
that they don't accept me or if they
actually offered me a job like I would
really really have to think about it but
I think I would say
no I feel like you would go through the
process and like you know where the
chips fall where they may like if you
got the job like if you didn't get the
job it was meant to be and then if you
got the job you would really consider it
and I could see you considering it to
the point of accepting it I would
consider it but honestly I think as I
get older when I was younger I would
have done it in a second I think it was
like probably a goal of mine at some
point yeah I think it's the reason I got
married like for real however I think as
I get older like it's important to bloom
where you're planted feel like we have
such a good thing going here like in
terms of my career this because like say
you did the show and then like say you
were on for two or three seasons
whenever you got off the show like then
you're just like a former housewife with
a podcast and like that's just not our
Vibe here and you know there's really
only one person in the Bravo sphere who
has negated that sort of Trope and
that's Hannah burner people don't even
think of her anymore as an ex- reality
star and that's so am for her every time
she comes on the toes I say like I'm so
impressed and happy for you cuz it could
be a dark Road after you get fired from
a show like that and you still try to
live a public life cuz it was your
career and your you know your uh income
MH I always tell her that cuz it's so
impressive and I think she's the only
person I can think of
yeah who didn't like Denise Richards is
fine like who didn't have something
before yeah and who like arguably is
bigger and more beloved after leaving
the show yeah than when she was on on it
yeah and then at Bravo con like they
were asked like would would Hannah like
like Kyle and Amanda were like the ones
who like kicked her off and then so they
were asked like would you have her back
and they were like totally like course
I'm sure they Tik Tok followers yeah I'm
sure Hannah like loved hearing that do
you think she would go back never in her
life nor should she even if she wasn't
having this amazing success like she was
just on the Drew Barrymore show even if
she was literally living on the street
she would not go back
yeah that's crazy so you would consider
it I would consider it but I I really
don't think it's right for me but it
could also be amazing for our show like
love you on roony and then they want
more of you and they can have you every
day to be honest it be it would be one
of those things and actually it would be
something I weigh very heavily and
consider and talk to you and the family
about and I think ultimately you would
tell me not to do it I I likely would
yes cuz in in your words and you said
this once and it's how I think about
everything now like does the risk
outweigh the reward and for me it does
yeah I I would agree with me and agree
with you and agreeing with me but it's a
good question cuz a lot of people are
talking about me potentially being no
I'm kidding I not heard from anyone but
there could be like a huge huge like if
it all went well the reward could be
infinite the operative word being could
right like it could be like a Molly May
situation it could she like has made me
feel a little differently I would still
go with like myaut cuz not everyone gets
to be Molly May there's do you know how
many not Molly Mays there are Folly Fay
but she's got got me think like being a
little more optimistic but still
realistic sorry so no but it was
fabulous to hang with the
ladies oh and then I tagged Jessel in my
story being like Oh my God I met Jessel
because I was so excited and I saw that
she had messaged me previously cuz she's
like a fashion publicist and she had
invited me to an event that was featured
on the show when she had that thing at
her apartment for like for one of her
Brands and all the ladies were like wow
she she got like really major like
fashion people there and everyone was
like except not turty she couldn't get
turty everyone was like jessle could do
this and that's when like everybody kind
of like Turned like who was there like a
lot of fashion people whose names I
don't know and you wouldn't know either
but if you saw them like you know that
like older lady with the red Bob and
like the blush not Grace no not Grace
cottington but like she's like a classic
fashion guy and then like that guy with
the glasses you know okay do you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah but she
didn't get dirty there so she didn't but
I had seen I should have went I didn't
see the message you would have never
never but now you know for next time
yeah cuz I've actually I think one time
in my life been been to an event that
was being filmed for Bravo I think you
were there too for Margaret no also
um Fashion Week Kyle store in New York
this two you're right two events and we
got on TV we got on TV the Margaret one
was cut so it wasn't ever but it was
like a pride event in Jersey and let me
tell you I had no fun at either event
like it's really it's made for filming
it's not like a real event yeah you're
just like person in the background
watching the drama yeah so I I didn't
enjoy it there those events really
aren't fun no not if you want to be a
star no not if you want to like have fun
and like have a drink and dance they
can't even play music so true they're
not fun yeah but we did get on TV we did
that's funny um yeah Kyle by Eileen too
yeah so the event was really it was fast
lovely and we had a great time and it
was fun to be together all sisters get a
little Glam hang out with like fellow
celebrities it was good celebrate the
holidays usher in the holidays I love
we're not talking enough about we're not
talking and we actually haven't spoken
about it enough and and for that we
intend to do better because we're
listening we're listening to holiday
music and we're learning from scripture
from scripture happy holidays everyone
it's time to start celebrating and you
know when you'll it's really time rage
parel's Christmas decorations go up next
week so she was giving us a little
teaser about what we can expect she's
only doing one tree this year not two
Drew is very happy about that so I think
it's the one tree is going to be like
the biggest and the baddest she's also
incorporating a splash of maroon into
her Decor this year and I think that's
beautiful because ra says red is the
color of the Season red is the color of
the season I can't believe she never had
red in her Christmas decor before I
can't believe like there are people out
there who have houses and are of the
Catholic Christian faith and don't have
45 trees like not only do I live in an
apartment I'm also a Jew so like I
couldn't even have one if I tried but if
I could I would only be able to have one
your new apartment is tree friendly does
anybody any other like goam in no not
goam what's opposite of goam juw any
other juice or just people who aren't
like celebrating Christmas look at their
apartment during the winter season and
be like oh if I had a tree it would go
there cuz I do that I know exactly where
I would put it your old apartment like
there was nowhere for it the tree would
be like scraping up against allum no no
no it just like wasn't tree friendly
tree friendly this apartment is tree
friendly no I know I think all but you
know what else I've been thinking about
you know we have Hanukkah Han is good
but it's good we have Hanukkah and you
know you like candles
once a day for eight days and part of
the the the Mitzvah is to obviously
light the candle but then to publicize
the nce which means publicize the
miracle now my old Department I couldn't
publicize [__] because nobody could see
into my windows I lived in an alley no
but the brick wall knew about the
miracle the brick my brick wall knew
about the miracle he was an educated
brick wall okay in my new apartment I
can publicize the [__] out of my Nace
can't wait for someone to throw an egg
at my house yeah truly I'm G to get
egged got to publicize the Nace anything
for the Nace so it's holiday season and
that's really we're talking about enough
no we're not you're here and we're
disgusting is falling as car sing just
wasn't the same alone on Christmas Day I
got another one take a TI wait no take a
trip down candy can Lane with
me
confess I confess you're the
best best ever had
take a trip down candy can Lane with me
so yeah that Season's Upon Us and that's
exciting it is it is it is should we
dive in we've got five stories the SAG
Afra news that we've all been waiting
for my gosh you guys sag
Afra we have CMA Awards it's bittersweet
yeah we'll talk let's talk about it okay
so we'll get into it we also have the
CMA Awards and like I have a lot to say
great because I didn't watch them did
you watch them we were out no I have a
lot to say about like the results oh
about the
Awards themselves unburden yourselves
CMAs without further Ado it is time for
the fast side stories that you need to
know today's episode of the toast is
brought to you by the farmer's dog so
the results of switching your dog food
from kibble to Fresh can seem like magic
when a senior dog starts acting like a
puppy again and the pickiest of eaters
can't wait for dinner time you might
think that some spells were cast but the
farmer's dog doesn't use any sorcery or
secret ingredients to make their fresh
food they just use science so what is
the dog they make and deliver fresh
healthy food for your dog it's developed
by vets it's nutritionally balanced and
it's made from real healthy ingredients
it's made to human food safety standards
it is the best option for dogs at all
life stages because it's not kibble and
it's not canned goo it's just real
healthy food traditional dry and wet dog
food options are highly processed they
can use much lower quality ingredients
than they claim to and they are
extremely difficult to portion
accurately the farmer's dog is not just
fresh higher quality food they also send
the food pre-portioned specifically for
your dog based on their unique
nutritional needs this makes it easy to
help your dog maintain their ideal
weight which is one of the biggest
indicators of a full healthy life dogs
at a healthy weight can live up to two
and a half years longer than overweight
dogs if you have a strice bro in your
life I mean I've been experiencing this
recently like their health their
wellbeing is the most important thing
and what you give them twice a day or
three times a day depending on what kind
of mom you are is so important I
switched to fresh healthy dog food from
the far farmers's dog a little while ago
immediate results Theo's breath was so
much better his poops were more
consistent his coat was really shiny he
felt energy
I've heard of Senior Dogs who get like
new leases on life when they switch to
fresh healthy food so it doesn't matter
if your dog is young or old it's always
the right time to begin investing in
their health get 50% off your first box
of fresh healthy food at
thefarmersdog.com toast plus you get
free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com toast
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50% off
your first box and free shipping today's
episode is also brought to you by game
time you shouldn't have to worry about
when to buy tickets for your next big
event game time is the fast and easy way
to buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and Theater events near you with
killer last minute deals all in prices
views from your seat and their best
price guad oned game time takes the
guest workk out of buying tickets game
time's a great app just to have on your
phone for wherever you are if you live
in a fabulous City with lots of fabulous
events like I do or if you travel a lot
for work and you know you have a night
off oh look there's a basketball game oh
a comedy show just a great way to like
explore and find things to do in your
city or a city you're traveling to and
it's the only ticketing app that gives
you complete peace of mind with your
purchase you can buy ticket tickets in
seconds all they offer all in pricing so
you show the total upfront you know
where your paying and you know you're
getting a great deal before you check
out and you could see the view from your
seat before you buy so you know exactly
what to expect they have deals on
tickets right up to the start of the
event even up to an hour after it starts
you can find exclusive Flash Deals
sponsored deals on tickets for football
basketball baseball com concerts comedy
theater and more with Zone deals you
pick the section and Game Time picks the
seats which is Big Time for savings and
the game time guadan means you'll always
get the best price if you find tickets
in the same section and row for Less
game time will credit you 110% of the
difference so take the guest workk out
of of buying tickets with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for $20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account and redeem code t o a
s for $20 off download the game time app
today last minute tickets lowest price
gued and make sure to use code toast for
$20 off your first purchase on the game
time app today's episode is also brought
to you by Squarespace the allinone
website platform for entrepreneurs to
stand out and succeed online whether
you're just starting out or managing a
growing brand Square space makes it easy
to create a beautiful website engage
with your audience and sell anything
from products to content to time all in
one place all on your terms so whatever
reason you might be having for starting
a website whether you work in e-commerce
you want to start a side business you're
a photographer there is a temp a
template on Squarespace for you you want
to upload an asset Library you can
upload organize and access all your
content from one place with the new
asset Library you're able to manage all
your files from one Central Hub and use
them across the Squarespace platform if
you're looking to sell merch custom
merch you can easily sell custom merge
and create passive income that
streams passive income streams that
engage your audience and scale your
brand so if you have an online store
it's super easy with Squarespace if you
want to host a video collection do email
campaigns whatever it is what I love
about Squarespace and so many people use
websites for e-commerce is that if you
want to sell in person they have a point
of sale you can connect a square reader
to the Squarespace app and you'll keep
your orders your inventory and your
customer data all in sync with your
online store so Squarespace is the place
to be if you're looking for a website
it's much more cost- effective but it'll
look like you hired a fancy schmancy
company to design a website for you so
head to squarespace.com right now for a
free trial when you're ready to launch
go to squarespace.com toast you'll save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain that's Square SQ a
space.com toast to save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
thank you
L um first story the strike is over sag
Afra and the Studios have reached a
tentative deal on new three-year
contract emphasis on the word tentative
emphasis on tentative and three years
like we're going to have to do this
again three years or maybe within these
three years they can reach a deal that's
not so tentative I also feel like a
couple of weeks ago it was like oh
they're back at the table tentative
something this feels more conclusive
because everybody's talking about it
like everyone's acting like it's over
but last time there was something but
you knew it like wasn't going to last
right so for now I'm just assuming like
the strike is fully over yeah cuz this
is everyone's acting like this is the
news they we're waiting for you know and
for sure like put out a statement we did
it you know yeah so after 118 days of
the actor's guil being out on strike tag
Afra and the studios on Wednesday
reached a tentative deal on a new
contract that can see Hollywood up and
running again within weeks the strike
will be over as of 12:01 a.m. Pacific
Time on today oh putting an end to more
than seven months of Labor unrest in
Hollywood that saw the writer Guild and
zag Afra hit the pick line I know that
Afra doesn't have an s in it and
everyone's like jaie you're reading it
wrong it's sag Afra to me and always is
a scratch in my brain Yeah scratch is an
itch in my mouth yeah sagra sagra hit
the picket lines in the industry's first
joint strike in more than 60 years
culminating a dramatic day of Studio
earnings results and deadline ultimatums
the actor guilded 17 member negotiating
committee unanimously voted this
afternoon to recommend a tentative
agreement to the sagra board okay
specific details of the deal are
expected to be revealed when the
agreement goes to the board on Friday
yes I don't know what the deal is I was
looking for it like what's going to
happen with AI what's going happen with
the extras like all the Talking Points
we've been talking about what does it
mean for the Stream but what does it
really mean for us let's talk about that
because that means this means like yes
everyone's going back to work fabulous
we love but we can't talk about the SAG
after strike anymore and that's kind of
been a Cornerstone of our show for for
like since the summer yeah like we
always have seasons of what we talk
about like it's Travis and Taylor or the
Kardashians or the Royals and like it's
been sag Afra and so it's bittersweet to
say goodbye to this chapter if you know
it is goodbye if it is indeed but I do
feel like things were getting a little
long in the tooth with sag after
especially after Halloween so there was
like a lot of infighting within members
at first it was sag after strong oh my
God you did not step out of sag after
strong first of sag out strong everybody
t-shirts signs picking no sort of unrest
within the community then the Halloween
thing tipped people off and also it was
just going on long and of course
everybody knows that like they were
trying to get the best deal but a deal
is better than no deal and people were
like listen it's just really dragging on
right now oh my God and then like the
Drew Barrymore era I forgot about that
so I do feel like there was a lot of
unrest within the actual Union and they
needed to get it done yeah because
people weren't working and I'm sure
there were people that were feeling like
maybe I should just go get a job like I
think that they needed
to put an end to the strike and a deal
any deal is better than no deal right
Deal or No Deal de I'm going to go with
deal deal so they have a tentative deal
and yeah but I agree it's been a big
part of um the fast di stories around
here you were going to miss it let's
let's let's lay this to rest like and
give it a proper finale what was your
favorite moment of the SAG after strike
I actually really enjoyed talking about
the daytime hosts like Bill Maher
Jennifer Hudson and people's um
decision-making during that time because
obviously daytime talk show they have
writers but it's not scripted so it kind
of fell in this like weird in between
space and a lot of people were going to
go back with that writers we remember
what happened and following like
celebrities being messy like I'm going
to do this actually no I'm doing this oh
actually I'm going to do this that was
interesting and I also just thought it
was interesting that somebody was doing
something
that they knew they were going to get
backlash for it but still felt strongly
enough to do it popular but felt like
the right thing to do yeah I thought
that was just an interesting time I
actually enjoyed commenting on that yeah
because you were able to have an
opinion there were takes to be had right
it wasn't just like obviously we all
think like yeah sag should get better we
all agree with this with the Union like
scab scab sag should be
better but then Drew was just like
[__] [__] up you know yeah what was
your favorite part I did enjoy that part
because it allowed um for nuanced
opinions and conversation I really
enjoyed being called a scab um we were
called scabs just for asking questions
that was you know funny for me you know
what else I really enjoyed I really
enjoyed seeing people who I like follow
on Instagram get opportunities that they
wouldn't ordinarily gotten because
celebrities weren't able to go ons or do
any form of press for um any projects
and they really didn't even have any
projects coming up and if they did they
weren't allowed to talk about them so I
thought it was cool to see people you
know getting opportunities who probably
wouldn't because it would be competing
with you know everybody else but because
all these actors and people in Sag had
to take a step back and not do things
that they wouldn't ordinarily do it kind
of gave a platform for other people to
get those opportunities you know what I
mean yeah do you think that anything
that happened for us
had to did we benefit from the strike at
all no have you been on like any have
you gotten anything I don't think so no
I'm just trying to no I don't no I don't
think so no but I'm happy for everyone
that did um benefit like that was cool
to see like influencers or um like
digital people being tapped for things
because sag members were unavailable
yeah yeah so hopefully this is it and
that the tentative deal becomes a final
deal and as much as like talking about
it like I am over it I want people to
get back to work people need to work
content needs to resume resume and
that's the way of things but that's just
the way it is I do look forward to
hearing the deal points and how they got
better got better and got on the same
page who really had to give who really
took I think sag probably had to give
I'm sure they ended up with a better
deal than they initially had but
probably not all the things that they
wanted yeah it's interesting yeah so are
you ready for our next story the other
big news of the day the CMA Awards were
on last night the Stars hit the carpet
looking gorgeous and we have the winners
shall we yeah so last night was the
night of Laney Wilson she swept the
awards Entertainer of the Year which is
the big prestigious Award of the night
so that's what I want to talk about when
tany Wilson she was up against Luke
Holmes Chris Stapleton Carrie Underwood
and Morgan Wallen so before I say
anything I want to say I'm an enormous
Laney Wilson fan I've seen her perform I
think twice song Greece is my go-to
Trill song it's so good I saw her at the
ACM Awards perform Greece and I was like
she's not human like she's incredible so
nothing I'm about to say is in any way
like a dig towards Lany Wilson I I just
feel like that's important to say
Entertainer of the Year is this massive
award it's the equivalent of like record
uh I mean album of the year at the
Grammys that's like the big award that
everybody stays and waits for now that
award never goes to a woman Miranda
Lambert and Carrie Underwood are always
nominated almost like seriously like
just to to say that they nominated two
women they never went
a woman hasn't won since 2011 Carrie and
Miranda are always up for it they they
know she's never oh and I think the last
time they won they gave it to both of
them okay like such [__] okay now as
a country music fan myself it's it's
it's not even my opinion it's sheer fact
that the entertainers of the year were
Luke Holmes and Morgan Wallen yeah they
went on the same size tour as Taylor
Swift Luke Holmes just got back from
Australia to play country music like
well they a a lot of country music in
Australia but yeah do you know a country
music I mean he was also in Scotland in
a kill country music is Australia is 19
hours away like I'm just saying it's so
it's another world yeah
and it's actually just like inaccurate
for her to have won and it actually
bothers me that they gave it to her
because it almost feels like they only
gave it to her because she's a woman
which is feels like so invalid and there
were so many other years where like the
women were were actual contenders like
doing Stadium tours headlining the Super
Bowl like there were years where the W
like the women who were nominated were
the entertainers of the year and they
didn't even get it then yeah so like for
me for her to get it I just feel like it
kind of like is a slap in the face to
women in com comedy women in music
because like she clearly wasn't do you
know what I mean yeah and so it feels
like she got it because she's woman the
bar is like lower for women yeah like
how can you really Lany Wilson opened
for Luke Holmes's stadium tour like it
doesn't make sense and she's amazing and
her songs play all over the radio and no
she's amazing she's everywhere I love
her she's only at the beginning of her
career by the way she won new artist of
the year when we were oh no I was in
Vegas what year was that two years ago
so she won new artist of the year two
years ago she's brand new no the fact
that she opened up for Luke Holmes just
tells you what you need to know like and
I hate to be like a naysayer because we
should be celebrating the fact that a
woman won but if you're like a a fan of
country music like you know this isn't
accurate and then it just kind of it
you're right it sets the bar Lower for
women yeah it was like Luke Holmes and
Morgan Wallen are doing things her
country music that are historic they're
they're doing things music that are
historic like at the top of the
Billboard charts like I think Luke had
like two top five or hits they were like
1 two 3 four five for a while like it's
a Luke Holmes or a Morgan Wallen song
has been on the the number one country
and also like top five of all billboard
for the entire year a week has not gone
by of all billboard it's the two of them
like come on yeah and even if you wanted
to give it to a woman actually Carrie
Underwood is doing a v Vegas residency
she's the Super Bowl Queen of the NFL
like she could get it at any she did a
stadium tour she did two nights at MSG
by herself headlining like
she like for Carrie Underwood to sit
there seriously after year after year
after year of getting slapped in the
face for it to go to a woman who's not
her like I'm sorry like that's [__]
yeah and again this has nothing to do
with Lany Wilson I love her yeah and she
will have her time she will it's all
ahead of her is how it feels like she
just got who else was nominated Chris
daeton yeah he headline Stage Coach like
he could always win but also like
annoying when he wins everything because
there are other people who are talented
there are but like he wins everything
for a reason so like I could the thing
is anybody could make an argument steton
is on a tour right now you could make an
argument for really anyone who was
nominated except Lany Wilson yeah unless
I'm missing something which I'm totally
possibly missing something she's doing
big things in entertainment but like not
a Taylor Swift size tour yeah no I mean
she was on Yellowstone yeah that's what
I was thinking as well I was shocked
yeah that is pretty honest if we really
want to talk about like who had a big
year as a woman in country like where's
Kelsey ballerini she made a lot of waves
yeah with rolling out the welcome at
yeah so I'm just saying single of the
year went to Fast Car by Luke Holmes
love you know how I
feel album of the year went to Lany
Wilson this is really hard for me um
because my album album of the year is
getting old by Luke Holmes of course
what else was nominated um Ashley
McBride and Morgan Wallin one thing at a
time and rolling up the welcome map by
Kelsey ballerini oh okay um I love a lot
of the songs from Lenny Wilson's album
it wasn't my album of the year but that
doesn't make it an incorrect Choice
she's amazing like sure I think honestly
they all could you could have made an
argument for any of these albums to win
for sure but again like Luke and
Morgan's albums have been like colossal
this year the thing is with Morgan is
that they've recently started to
incorporate him back into like the
country things like nominating him I
don't think he will ever win not for a
while not right now so fine so like I
don't even consider like I'm not even
going to make a case for him because
like I think remember CMT took yes CMT
took him off yeah oh and by the way when
they when they announced Lany Wilson
they cut to Luke and they cut to Morgan
and like they were both like honestly
mad as they should be they're doing
they're trailblazing and like and
they're huge country guys they're always
having what they're doing is UN has not
been done before no and I have long said
I feel like a few years ago when we did
like a CMA CMA recap I said it's always
like the same people like Jason Al Luke
Bryan Blake Shelton who get nominated
and win Entertainer of the yearn like
honestly they suck Eric Church I don't
include Eric Church in that group I
think he's like Standalone but like I
always say it's like for a while it was
like those men of country music who
really stunk like I'm sorry they're so
basic and whatever like they don't make
waves in music they're just like famous
because they make like catch country
songs like Luke and Morgan are in on
another planet right now for sure this
year for sure for me for sure anyways I
would have said and I like Morgan
wallen's album I've actually been
listening to it like now I have the time
for it me too but Luke's is better
Luke's
album is unbelievable wait speaking of
Morgan and Luke I told you this in the
car on the way home yesterday um so the
night before the CMA Awards every year
is this thing called BMI and it's like
the organization of songwriters it's
kind of like sag I think for songwriters
and they have like a big fancy ceremony
they get song writer of the Year Luke
was it this year but what they did that
made a lot of waves is that they have
performers it doesn't get like televised
anywhere but there's like videos and
stuff of it Luke and Morgan Wallen
actually performed together which they I
don't think they ever done and they sang
each other's songs so Luke Sayang
thought you should know by Morgan Wallen
and Morgan Wallen saying going going
gone by Luke Holmes and it was kind of a
big deal because people are always
talking about these two I think a lot of
people think there's beef I I don't
think that there is I think uh Luke was
asked about it and he was like is there
any competition and Luke was like yeah
but not in a negative way like
competition is healthy like you want to
be challenged and have somebody who's
doing the same sort of thing as you so
you can constantly be like getting
better so they definitely see each other
but people always like collab collab and
like no they don't no but I saw a video
recently of I think it was Luke doing or
Morgan s a little bit like my daddy yeah
I think before Luke really really blew
up and Morgan like was releasing music
like they have both covered old video
yes they have both covered each other's
songs there video of
um Morgan singing something and there's
a video of Luke singing she sounds a
little bit like my daddy I don't cuss
around my mama okay cuz I saw that
recently and I was like hey but now no
they're both old uh well there's room
for everyone they're literally my top
two favorite artists so there's no
competition I have room in my earbuds
for both of them yeah song of the year
Crazy Fast Car song writer Tracy Chapman
oh I love this for Tracy Chapman right
imagine like I don't know 20 years after
writing a song you win song of the year
in another category L go up like I don't
know who goes up did Tracy go up I don't
know if she was there that's so
interesting
yeah that's so crazy that's cool that is
cool female vocalist of the Year
obviously went to Laney Wilson because
you can't be the Entertainer VI also
winning your category male vocalist of
the year went to Chris
Stapleton yeah yeah but like the thing
is Luke I me too we're by the way we're
biased we have to acknowledge that but
also so I don't get mad when somebody
wins and like I could make an argument
for it you know yeah no but yes yes yes
vocal group of the year old dominion
there's like not even a competition well
lady a they're my vocal group every year
but acknowledge your own bias
acknowledge that you know it's just one
of those things that I like more than
the average person Little Big Town
Midland and Zack Brown Band they're also
oh Z Brown B yeah vocal Duo of the Year
Brothers Osborne love them they and I
was going to say the best thing ever
happened to Brothers Osborne is Florida
Georgia Line breaking up and whatever
happened with scoter Braun and Dan and
Shay because like they kind of fell off
the face of the planet they just put out
a new album though and it's really good
but they're I never said they weren't
talented but they were like for a minute
like every song they made billion
streams billion streams and then like
they took some time off and I think they
said that they actually experienced like
a lot of conflict between the two of
them and then I feel like they went
through something weird with their
management they just kind of fell off
the face of the Earth yeah so it's just
a series of fortunate events for the
Brothers Osborne who are brothers and
are tight and they work hard and they
just keep their heads down you know yep
and then the other big category was new
artist of the year and that went to
Jelly Roll which that's actually was a
stiff competition because you had Zach
Bryan who's like doing crazy things in
music oh and Megan [__] okay by the way
I'm sorry like Zack Bryan should have
won and I don't even like listen to Zack
Bryan but like I know yeah he's doing
crazy things he's doing by the way he's
literally new
artist Contender and does stadiums like
I'm sorry but does he have a record
label I don't know why yeah something
about him I don't know if it's just like
my independent energy like I feel like
he's like the Frank Ocean of country
music he's definitely like a renegade
Outlaw but I think that's just like his
brand Zack Bryan record label I feel
like he's indep he's at Capital Records
he's fine why do I think that he's just
like because that's how good his
branding is totally yeah he's just like
an outlaw with his rope and I mean for
me the new new artist of the year would
have been Megan [__] but I can
acknowledge my bias in that yeah yeah
she's small time compared to Zack Bryan
and jelly roll right but I do think an
argum man can make me for a jelly roll
yeah but I think the thing is that for
me and his wife is a podcaster so we
have no choice to we love love love love
love love love to see podcasts suring
and he's amazing I watched his
documentary I feel like I did a whole
episode on it yeah I just think Zack
Bryant is currently bigger yeah but it
worked in my head when he was
independent cuz it's like okay then he's
not going to get Awards he didn't have
the campaign yeah right right right you
have to campaign for these Awards and
because he doesn't have a label anyone
speaking on his behalf he didn't get it
yeah so I like that narrative better
you're welcome um but anyways the
girlies were looking good Lany Wilson
looked incredible I loved her outfit
because I love that it was like fashion
but also super country that's so her by
the way like I think that was the name
of her album bell bottom country like
she loves clothes she's so girly but
she's really like she represents for a
lot of people like everybody loves like
the curent country music like isn't
country she represents for a lot of
people like country music bringing back
country music her outfit was Carolina
Herrera wow and it's giving my wedding
dress let me see I love and by the way
have you seen her boyfriend he's so hot
it's they a smut novel oh my God you
need to see a picture of her and her
boyfriend and then listen to the song
Greece which is all about like having a
man with dirty hands come home and it's
it's an Obel it's Danelle steel it's
Colin Hoover it's looks so beautiful
haven't seen the red carpet pictures I
love her dress okay you like aren't
showing me they're beheaded they've been
beheaded on the iPad so cute I'm
obsessed so cute I'm
obsessed post Malone was there yeah he
respects the hell out of country music
and they respect the hell out of him him
Morgan Wallen Hardy and some other guy
started like a band together and they
just released three songs oh I think I
saw some of it and Morgan Wen was there
and he cut his hair he looks hot as hell
yeah but I like the
mullet no I liked the mullet also I
heard a rumor I think I read onor H was
there yeah I know I hope she met someone
me too she would I saw it on her Tik Tok
um I read a thing I think maybe like J
or whatever that Harry Styles has a buzz
cut now breaking news oh I could see
that being handsome I the thing is there
are like certain people and there's not
a lot of them but Harry Styles is
definitely one of those like faces
anything works yeah and they're all my
favorite kind of like David Beckham
remember in the documentary he had so
many hairstyles honestly DTF for each
one yeah each one was better than the
last I agree I would love to see Buzz
Harry yeah I think I saw like a very
blurry dark silhouette of him and he
appeared to have a but he looks like
David Beckham yeah no he he he can pull
anything off yeah okay well that's your
CMA recap I wish I got a chance to watch
it me too it's always a fun night in
country music but I'm sure if there were
any great performances they'll make
their way to me yeah I'm just going to
sit back and receive them yeah let them
come to you are you ready for our next I
don't chase I attract what is mine will
find me what literally are you ready for
our next story mhm Robert Kardashian
wanted to marry Priscilla Presley until
she cooked for him me me Priscilla
Presley who divorced Elvis Presley 50
years ago after a turbulent six-year
marriage claimed in a q event last week
that she had never wanted to marry after
H after Elvis because no one could ever
match the music legend however that's
not the whole story in the mid 70s after
her split from Elvis she fell head over
heels for Robert Kardashian before he
married Chris an Insider said that um
Robert was at one time desperate to
marry her uh they said quote Priscilla
made Robert very happy he wanted to
marry her and have children with her
that was definitely his hope his plan
the two were intimate virtually from the
moment they met and it was love at first
sight it's really so crazy things like
this just always remind me because they
need to be reminded like the Kardashians
really come from like La royalty yeah
and they're connected in so many
different ways to so many different
people I mean
OJ Elvis now Elvis even before there was
an Elvis connection because Lind Linda
Thompson who was married to Caitlyn is
that's Brody Jenner and Brendon Jenner's
mom yeah dated Elvis after prisilla yes
um a close friend recalled that Robert
vehemently complained how
um while he was making love to Priscilla
Elvis would Elvis would ring her up
sounding
incoherent um and also Robert's close
friend Larry cranes I believe that
Todd's father father of Todd remembered
Robert telling that Priscilla was
terrific but this guy Elvis doesn't stop
controlling her oh wow that's a lot to
get into yeah I also did see um because
Priscilla's doing like another round of
press because of the Priscilla movie I
believe it was Gail King or someone
maybe it wasn't Gail King asking her
like finally like you were 14 he was 24
you know like let's talk about that yeah
and she maintains that it was very
innocent very nonsexual for a while
while and even though he was 24 he
always treated her with respect and
she's not a he wasn't a groomer and she
doesn't feel like it was predatory in
any way she maintains that yeah I read
her book and that's the story that she's
telling they like had a relationship but
it wasn't sexual for a few years and
then they got
married like it's weird no like I just
feel like I love I love storytelling as
much as like and I love great romances
and like I could look past things you
know I just think we should be talking
about how weird it is you know we could
still romanticize Pilla the movie on the
scale of weird things that are seen it's
not that high up for me especially
because like they then got married and
they had a totally F Trad traditional
relationship so yeah
it's if you want to dig into it but it's
literally 50 years ago and it alive and
it worked out for them and she doesn't
see it that way and she's a grown woman
now okay let me ask you another question
what do you think is weirder okay
14-year-old Priscilla 24-year-old Elvis
starting a relationship although it
wasn't sexual but they met at that age
and ended up getting married and like
having sex or not when she was 14 but
yeah no I said ended up yeah no my not
you defending them um or Woody Allen
Sunni what are the what were the ages
there so I mean there's a big age Gap
but she was of age when they but it's we
because he was temporary stepfather
yeah yes what do you think is weirder
it's a good question I guess that one
what because of the family connection
yeah yeah I actually think Elvis is
weirder cuz the thing is I mean it's
[__] weird what Woody Allen did but
they were never related they aren't
related and she was of age yeah so he
didn't you know break any laws it's just
weird yeah yeah Elvis's is you know
borderline illegal but he didn't break
any laws if he waited until she was of
age yeah but do you just not believe
that they waited oh no no I I mean I
don't know I've never thought no one's
ever asked me that question before so
like if if they met when she was 14 and
I forget the details from her book but
say they didn't consummate until she was
17 or 18 that would make him 27 28
yeah if you believe that okay I never
thought much about whether or not I
believed it that's good question um I
guess and I I believe it because I read
the book yeah well I didn't read the
book so just based on my very limited
knowledge if you ask me if I believed it
like I would say no okay and I believe
it because I read it the book and I just
don't think she would spend that much
time lying in her Memoir yeah no like
why write a book if you're just going to
lie right like your Memoir is like
written by you like that's going to be
here you leave like don't tell lies by
the way I feel like I'm really cutting
you off a lot today I could feel it I'm
sorry oh I don't feel it you're fine
keep
D no no so do you believe it I just
answered your question I wasn't
listening I said because like I don't
know a lot no so that's why it's weird
because you think he was you know with a
14-year-old yeah so did you answer my
Woody Allen question which one did you
think was Weir I thought I guess Woody
Allen's weirder because of the con
yeah and because I've like made peace
with Elvis and Priscilla yeah yeah yeah
you know for me personally maybe you
need to see the movie Priscilla see it
from Priscilla's POV because it is based
on her book right fine I would love to
do that I also I did watch the Mia faroh
that was [__] wild I didn't watch it
it wasn't even so much I don't really
have opinions it wasn't even so much
about Sun it was just about the insane
way all those kids grew up are Woody and
soon still together I think Woody and
soon are still an item yeah
huh there's proof in the pudding I know
like it's weird it's weird cuz at some
point like no matter how weird it is
when two people get together if they're
together for such a long amount of time
like you just have to like kind of
accept it yeah it's meant to be somebody
steals your boyfriend and you're so mad
but then what you're going to be mad at
them when they're 90 years old and still
in love like you got to get over they
beared and you weren't you you were in
the way right get the [__] out of the
way you were standing in the way of true
love yeah are you ready for our next
story MH this story is really crazy um
Katy Perry and Orlando broom have made
progress in their legal fight over the
$15 million Mount too home with man who
says he was in a post-operative delirium
when he sold his home to the Stars man
who sold his to the stars is camon
wescott's father-in-law his name is Carl
Wescott he's and he started w00 flowers
and last time we were on the toast I
misspoke and said that it was her father
and that Cameron comes from a lot of
money too she I'm sure she does it's her
husband's 1 1800 Flowers yes so he's a
businessman Carl Wescott he's 84 he's
also a veteran which you know doesn't
look good for the IM wise for the Perry
Bloom camp but Katy Perry and Orlando
Bloom have cleared a legal hurdle in
their ongoing legal battle with
businessman Carl Wescott father-in-law
of Cameron Wescott who said says he was
medicated at the time he decided to sell
his home to the pop star Carl Wescott
father-in-law of Cameron Wescott who
finalized the sale of his home to Katy
Perry in July of 2020 has sought the
court to overturn the sale saying he was
under the influence of pain medication
when he agreed to sell the 8-bedroom 11
bathroom home he subsequently sued Katy
Perry's business manager the month after
the sale went through as the trial
commences past September the judge split
up the parties in the case as Katie has
counter sued Carl over damages as a
result of the real estate row on
Wednesday in La Superior Superior Court
a judge issued a tentative ruling that
Carl was in his right mind when he
proceeded with the real estate sale more
than 3 years ago people reported after
reviewing the docs okay
like you know order of the Court like he
said what he said but you know it's got
me thinking okay so she like bought this
house there's so many other houses like
would you just like give it back just to
not have your name and by the way
legally it sounds actually like Katy
Perry didn't do anything wrong but all
we see is the headline she's being sued
by an ancient uh veteran like what what
you just rather give the house back and
avoid all the drama yes but what she
bought it in July 2020 like they're in
the house I'm sure oh July 2020 I'm
sorry maybe they start a construction
it's her daughter so probably the home
she was born in sorry sorry I didn't put
that together you're 100% right and now
and like I feel like for both parties
honestly like you both have a ton of
money one of you find another house it's
hard to F like feel um any sort of
empathy for these people you know yeah
no it's like it's inconvenient I don't
know what's been going on with Carl
since this happened where is he living
what what is his history with the house
like maybe what if he has my favorite
dog is buried in the yard maybe it's the
house that built him maybe it's the
house that built him and also for Katie
it's the house that like built her
daughter built and everybody has ties to
this house that's the thing about houses
it's like they never really belong to
you yeah but it's also it's a very
emotional thing it's not just a real
estate transaction no no I was having
this conversation recently actually with
some friends cuz you know friends break
up friends get buried strangers get
bored and strangers get buried like a
part of growing up is like you know
things change maybe your parents get
divorced whatever you the house you grew
up in usually doesn't stay in your
family like they sell it for another
family and it's like always so sad yeah
it's like really hard actually yeah
because it's the house that buil that
was like last season on Southern Charm
Austin's parents were moving out of his
family home and for some reason like it
really was emotional for me even though
I've never had that like we just don't
have that sort had that sort of
experience um but I was just like really
feeling for the crel family no by the
way it's like a weird part of like
growing up it's like the acknowledgement
that your parents are getting older and
that like you're kind of taking on the
responsibility now and also that you
have to like say goodbye to your
childhood room like say goodbye to your
childhood you are grown now goodby no
it's pathetic like it's so sad it's
really hard yeah I think it depends when
it happens for you but I think if you're
like used to moving and then it's not a
big deal but if it was like the home you
were born into and then like your your
parents are moving out when you're 30
it's hard it's a lot yeah are you ready
for our fifth and final story no no cuz
I have something to say and then you
have something to say do you know do you
know that yes and yes well today's
episode of the toast is sponsored by
better help this time of year can
definitely be a lot it's natural to feel
some sadness or anxiety about it but
adding something new and positive to
your life can counteract some of those
feelings therapy can be a bright spot
amid all the stress and change something
to look forward to to make you feel
grounded and to give you the tools to
manage everything going on and better
help is amazing for a time like this
it's so true holiday season I feel like
a lot of people feel very overwhelmed it
can be lonely it can be isolating can
also just be like too much even if like
you know you have a lot of people around
you could just be like uncomfortable and
overwhelming and having an outlet and
someone to talk to is amazing and and
having better help is so great because
if you're traveling a lot for the
holidays better help is done all through
your phone so you'll always have someone
to talk to if you're thinking of giving
therapy a start give better help a try
it's done entirely online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapist any time for no addition
charge that's the best part of better
help because such a natural part of
therapy is like not vibing with the
first person you meet it could be really
awkward in person to have to like cancel
and go to someone else ask for a
referral it's just like horrible and
awkward it's all done entire it's done
online excuse me bless you s's done it
it's true better help is done online so
if you need to switch it's not awkward
at all and they'll they'll match you
with another person and it's all done
online so you can use whatever Medium
you're most comfortable with so you can
talk on the phone with your therapist
you can text you can video chat whatever
feels best to you so find your bright
spot this season with better help visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10%
off your first month that's better
hp.com toast betterhelp.com toast thank
you betterhelp for sponsoring today's
episode and today's episode is also
brought to you by Dreamland baby so
Dreamland baby is having their biggest
sale of the year if you go to Dreamland
baby co.com and use code the toast BOGO
23 at checkout for the buy 1 get one
free weighted products deal this is a
great way to stop stock up and Dreamland
baby products or to give the product as
a gift for the holidays oh that's a nice
gift for a new mom yeah so the Dreamland
dream weighted sleep sack is one of my
favorite baby products and once you're
obsessed with it you're going to need
two so now is the time to get one
because you're going to have one in the
laundry and you're going to need one on
hand and you're not going to want to be
waiting by the dryer waiting for it to
dry and feeling the moistness so now is
the time to get the Dreamland baby
weighted sleep sack we love them in our
home so the way that it works it has a
little bit of weighted on the top of the
Sleep sack which functions for your baby
the way a weighted blanket does for you
reduces you know anxiety stress helps
it's very calming will help you fall
asleep and will help you stay asleep so
it's been great for baby it could be
worn three different ways for babies of
all ages and depending on how your baby
likes to be swaddled it could be two
arms in one arm out or two arms out does
Charlie go do strong and he goes like
this yeah um I have done both both arms
in and both arms out they're both really
great ways for baby to sleep and as I
said they are having their biggest sale
of the year so head to Dreamland bab
cod.com and use code the toast BOGO 23
at checkout for the buy one get one free
weighted products deal if you are
looking for a sleeping solution for your
be I highly suggest you try the
Dreamland baby weighted sleep sack it is
a wonderful product for babies gorgeous
what's our fifth and final oh I got some
requests like people have really been
missing the final story song I know that
we're together that's wrong yeah I agree
so without further do it do it
do you want to you go no it's a high
note It's the final
Story the final
Story Woody and sun
[Applause]
or I want my dinner now
I want my lunch now yeah we will be
handling that what are you thinking
everything our fifth and final story
some actually crazy news um the shocking
moment G were you not wearing a hat I
was but I took it off during the first
ad break oh I totally miss that that was
intentional because two things it's warm
in here secondly hot I don't know how
that hot's going to look on the show so
I wanted half the show with hat and half
the show without so you can get clips
from both no and so like if it was good
I had it for half and if it was bad
thank God I took it off no I've
definitely been thinking I need to wear
hats more cuz I wore a hat recently cuz
like my hair was so ugly and I looked so
cute hats are like so cute and when you
have a good hat like we've made a couple
great merch hats I love this one I love
the black 100% hat that's like so cool
for like incognito mode right no cuz I'm
like a real house of New York yeah
aspiring yeah actually a hat would look
cute with your outfit like wait oh my
God Claude it's going to look so
cute
am I the coolest girl on the planet
obsessed okay I'll wait for the rest and
now I'll have clips from this and
without people we going to think it's
different
days we're so my that day I wore a
vest because those reals are fake
because that Fest was disgusting no no
no no no you missed the line
okay those rules are fake they were real
that day I wore a vest oh no those rules
aren't real they were real that day I
wore a vest because a vest was
disgusting that's really rude cuz I'm
wearing a vest today yeah yeah yeah it's
not disgusting no it's so cute it's from
Amazon it's in my storefront are you
ready for our fifth and final story now
which is not giving final story Vibes I
should have like shoved it in somewhere
else because it's like a rough note to
end on it's okay the shocking moment
galgadot screening of the Hamas terror
attack film ended in massive brawl
between protesters outside the Museum of
Tolerance you guys this you couldn't
make this up it was giving very
intolerant energy outside there wasn't
tolerance was the tolerance in the room
with us perfect A+ usage let me also say
the Museum of Tolerance is LA's
Holocaust Museum and I just want to say
if you find yourself outside of a
holocaust museum protesting like you
really need to seek help and just go
home you're in the wrong party and stay
home J get a job yeah videoos showed
fights between protesters outside the
Los Angeles Museum of Tolerance where
actress galado had organized a screeing
of footage of the brutal Hamas terror
attack atrocities committed during the
October 7th invasion of Israel the 47
minute footage provided by the IDF was
aired to a select audience of
celebrities and influential
personalities in LA and New York last
night does it say he was there like I'm
dying to know no major Hollywood stars
were there according to the LA Times
They also said it might have been due to
the SAG after strike sure no by the way
remember like for three years when you
didn't want to go somewhere or something
happened like you blamed everything on
Co now we're I guess we're the strike is
over and what the hell does this
screening this isn't a Oscar winning
film it's literally real footage does it
to do actors like that's like no that's
such a lie yeah I don't know why one has
to do with the other also I feel like
agod do actually has a lot of famous
friends she's like such a weird level of
celebrity where she's literally been in
one thing and she's probably a list
forever like the Wonder Woman Trilogy
whatever it was so far literally
catapulted her to such an extraordinary
level of Fame she's like the global face
of Revlon keeping up with the Joneses
keeping up with the yeah she was in
other stuff too but like nothing like I
feel like she might and like one other
big thing that we she was in that movie
that we saw death on the Nile um yes
which we like she's also in Justice
League as Wonder Woman yeah she's a part
of that like crew yeah so she's so
famous I feel like I mean she was
responsible for the Imagine video and
how many aists were in there like she
knows a lot of a-listers so I find it
crazy that nobody went no I don't know
that nobody went um but not like
celebrities but still influential behind
the scenes people there are a lot of
people who are part of of Hollywood who
like make a difference and are
influential that aren't famous I also
think she's going to do more screenings
like I think this was just one night of
it um but there were about 200 people in
attendance and um I got like an
uncensored Tik Tok of like some of the
footage I flipped away so fast but like
I did see like stuff it was really like
I it was really upsetting it's so
upsetting and I don't understand what
there is to protest about people bearing
witness to something that happened like
what's the beef what's your message
what's the beef like I mean I think it's
my understand that people who protest
the screenings are people who don't
believe that the massacre happened they
think there aren't real hostages they
think that um there wasn't they like
they think it's Israeli propaganda so
the what the footage that they're
viewing they think is fake like made by
Israeli media like that's really what
they think but I think I me I don't know
but like the terror some of body cam
footage but some of it is like was
uploaded to telegram by the terrorist
themselves what do they say to that that
not that's not true like they just make
stuff up I can't jaie I really can't get
into the mindset of a mentally ill
person right right so I'm doing my best
okay right lay off okay no I'm just
trying to understand you know the cause
like what's the problem with viewing
because I if you're you know Pro
Palestinian and and uh advocating on
behalf of the Palestinian people like
that's you can be that but also
understand what that October 7th
happened you know like that's not
congress with one another so I don't
know who these people are and what their
cause is no I think that's their cause
but I guess part of their cause is
denying that this happened and dying
that people should see it even though
Hamas filmed it and wanted people to see
it no and they're like proud of it no
it's like that was like the Babylon B
headline that was like Hamas terrorists
upset that they filmed their entire
Massacre and like the people don't
believe yeah yeah I saw that too well
honestly good on Gago like enormous
respect for my Israeli Queen and just so
[__] so much FL a brawl broke out at the
Museum tolerance you really couldn't
write this stuff I I have enormous
respect I think that there are a few
celeb who are like taking Amy Schumer's
one of them taking so much [__] for just
like being proud Jews and supporters of
Israel and you know demanding the
hostages come home and I I imagine
that's extraordinarily difficult so I I
I stand with them at this time yeah no
but like once you've seen what happened
and if you're a Jew and especially for G
as an Israeli like nothing else matters
yeah if you're just a human being like
as it should be yeah so that was our
show nice long 1 hour show
tomorrow you're still in New York right
yeah we'll finish the show the week
together together how nice we're going
to hang out today and we're going to
hang out today maybe we'll get on the
same page tomorrow about like um dress
code dress code but it's Friday don't
come looking for me tomorrow I will be
wearing spat pants yeah cuz it's Friday
and it's chill and I think oh I have a
turtleneck or a sweatshirt I'll go
sweatshirt sweatshirt thank you guys so
much for listening to the toast L
Morning Show where we deliv the fast
stories you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcasting where podcast can be found so
Spotify public video I to cast boox all
the places we you list podcast might
also to about our beautiful standing and
what kly talented we are hope you guys
have a fabulous gorgeous amazing
splendid day and we'll see you tomorrow
love you
bye